la renuncia del magistrado luis arse al
jurado nacional de elecciones dejó cinco
euros al tribunal electoral en
circunstancias en que delibera las
impugnaciones presentadas por keiko
fujimori a las elecciones del 6 de junio
cárcel a pesar de estar impedido por ley
y renunciar dimitió al cargo y con esto
retrasa aún más la proclamación de pedro
castillo como presidente el magistrado
cuestionó la labor del organismo
electoral y afirmó que con su
alejamiento evita que sus votos sean
utilizados en lo que él llama falsas
deliberaciones constitucionales
representantes de pedro casi o vieron
con suspicacia la dimisión de arse
cuando el tribunal electoral había
rechazado las diez primeras peticiones
de nulidad presentadas por keiko
fujimori
en esa línea acusaron al fujimorismo de
promover un intento de golpe de estado
por su parte a los partidarios de keiko
fujimori rechazaron las acusaciones y
solicitaron una auditoría internacional
a los comicios del 6 de junio mientras
tanto la organización de los estados
americanos así como la unión europea
reafirman que el proceso electoral
peruano ha sido libre y democrático